la fin on a parlé des réseaux de
neurones et je vous ai dit que ça
ressemblait avant tout à une grosse
bidouille dégueulasse ce qui avait amené
le lait de 2011 à conclure que ça ne
pourrait jamais être bien utile et très
clairement si le lait de 2011 a conclu
cela c'est qu'il n'a pas lu l'article de
turing de 1950 dont on a longuement
parlé dans les épisodes 2 à 7 sur vous
un épisode 7
oui parce qu'en 1950 turing avait déjà
anticipé le fait que l'intelligence
artificielle de niveau humain émergerait
sans doute d'une bidouille de code
extrêmement sophistiqués guidés par des
données autrement dit turing avait
anticipé le machine learning
pour rappel dans l'épisode 7 on a vu que
turing avait compris que tout algorithme
très intelligent correspondait
nécessairement un code source
extrêmement longs sans doute d'au moins
1 gigaoctet
or écrire un tel code est une tâche
herculéenne qu'aucun humain ni groupe
d'humains ne serait capable de réaliser
en moins disons d'un siècle pour turing
la seule façon d'écrire un tel code
c'est de partir d'un algorithme initial
est de chercher à le complexifier au fur
et à mesure en le guidant à l'aide est
un très grand nombre de données
typiquement une façon d'implémenter les
idées de turing c'est de considérer que
notre algorithme contient un très grand
nombre de paramètres c'est-à-dire des
millions voire des milliards de boutons
à tourner et d'explorer les valeurs
possibles de ces paramètres en étant
guidé dans cette exploration par les
données selon turing ce nec ainsi
qu'après cet apprentissage on disposera
d'algorithmes de grande complexité
qu'ils soient nés en moins pertinent
pour des applications en lien avec le
monde réel
et bien ça c'est exactement le principe
d'une machine learning moderne ou
considère des modèles avec des millions
de boutons à ajuster et pendant la phase
dite d'apprentissage on exploite des
données pour déterminer dans quelle
direction tourner ses différents bouton
ok mais reste encore déterminer comment
ajuster les boutons en fonction de
chaque nouvelle donne est observé et là
on pourrait imaginer plusieurs façons de
faire en baliser un nom algorithmes
d'apprentissage préféré bien sûr la
formule de bêtises mais en bayésiens
pragmatique je sais aussi que la formule
de bay street hier des calculs beaucoup
trop long en pratique
en fait ce qui serait plus simple c'est
qu'étant donné les positions actuelles
les boutons et étant donné des données à
analyser on puisse déterminer exactement
les changements optimaux d'opposition
des boutons pour que notre machine
apprennent et bien ça c'est exactement
ce que propose la descente de gradient
pour comprendre cela prenons un cas
simples imaginons que la machine cherche
à reconnaître des chats on lui donne des
images en entrée et elle ressort un
nombre entre 0 et 1 qui est la
probabilité selon la machine que l'image
en question soit une image de chat pour
tester les performances de la machine on
peut lui donner plein d' image
différente quand on lui montre une image
où il n'ya pas de chat la machine est
censée répondre 0 mais de façon
intéressante on peut dire que si elle
répond 0,1 elle n'aura pas trop faux
revanche elle répond 0,9 au 1
là elle aura très fort une façon
classique de mesurer l'erreur de la
machine sur une image sans chars et de
calculer le carré de sa sortie ainsi
s'il n'y a pas de chat et si la machine
10 0,1 alors elle aura une petite
pénalité de 0,1 au carré qui est égal à
0,01
mais si elles disent 0,9 alors sa
pénalité sera alors 0,81
de façon générale si la machine répond
pas à une image son chat alors elle
recevra une pénalité égale
ap carey al'inverse ans montre une image
de chat la machine celle ci est censée
répondre quelque chose de très proche de
1,7 fois la pénalité du chat pourra être
mesurée par la quantité
un monte au carré ainsi si paix est égal
à 0,9 alors la pénalité sera un moins
0,9 au carré qui est égal à 0,1 au carré
kiéthéga les 0,01
ce qui est très faible
pour mesurer la performance de notre
machine on peut lui donner plein de
données par exemple des milliards de
photos et calculées les pénalités
moyenne de la machine ainsi une machine
avec une erreur quadratique moyenne de
0,25 sera plutôt mauvaise tandis qu'une
machine avec une erreur qu pratique
moyenne de 0,01 sera très bonne
l'erreur quadratique moyenne de la
machine est aussi appelée fonction de
perte ou l'osce fonctionnent en anglais
et au final le machine learning consiste
à déterminer les réglages de la machine
qui minimise cette fonction de pertes
reste maintenant à déterminer ses
réglages de la machine pour cela
considérons d'abord le cas simple où la
machine ne possède qu'un seul bouton qui
peut prendre des valeurs disons entre 0
et 100 si on est patient on peut tester
toutes les positions de la machine pour
chaque position peut ainsi déterminer
l'erreur moyenne de la machine avec le
réglage en question on peut même tracé
une courbe qui donne les erreurs de la
machine en fonction de la position du
bouton et sur ce graphe on voit alors
très bien ce qu'il faut faire pour
minimiser les erreurs de prédiction il
faut mettre le bouton à la position 42
hockey mais le problème c'est que ça
nous a pris un peu de temps et en
pratique il serait vraiment bon de
savoir si lorsqu'on est à la position 63
10 ans il vaut mieux tourner le bouton
vers la gauche ou vers la droite
mieux idéalement il serait bon de savoir
s'il faut beaucoup tourner à gauche
légèrement à gauche légèrement à droite
beaucoup à droite ou rester tel quel eh
bien il se trouve qu'en mathématiques il
existe un outil qui a été inventé pour
répondre à cette question
cet outil est appelée la dérivée de la
fonction de pertes en fonction du
réglage du bouton si cette dérive et est
très positive c'est qu'il nous faut
beaucoup tourner à gauche
et si elle est légèrement négative c'est
qu'il nous faut légèrement tourner à
droite
alors il y aurait beaucoup plus à dire
sur la dérive et malheureusement je ne
vais pas prendre le temps de bien en
parler mais j'ai fait pas mal de vidéos
sur ce sujet sur la chaîne loin de 10 da
pour ceux qui veulent en savoir plus ok
la dérive et ça marche bien dans le cas
où on n'a qu'un seul bouton à tourner
mais qu'en est il du cas où il ya
plusieurs boutons et bien tout bêtement
on peut regarder les effets de chaque
tournage de boutons sur les performances
de notre machine
dans le jargon on parle de dérivées
partielles de la fonction de pertes par
les réglages que chaque bouton on
obtient ainsi pour chaque bouton un
nombre qui nous dit à quel point il faut
tourner le bouton pour améliorer les
performances de la machine
la collection de ces nombres forme alors
un vecteur que l'on appelle le gradient
de la performance de l'âme
la chine par les réglages et bien
l'algorithme par descente de gradient ça
consiste tout bêtement à tourner les
boutons proportionnellement aux dérivées
partielles des boutons ou dit encore
autrement ce revient à suivre les
indications suggéré par le gradient et
comme ce gradient ai déduit des
performances de la machine qui sont
déduits des données d'entraînement de la
phase d'apprentissage
on voit bien en quoi l'algorithme par
descente de gradient correspond bien à
une exploration des réglages de la
machine
guidée par les données alors c'est bien
beau tout ça mais le problème en général
c'est que calculé le gradient peut être
un problème très difficile en tant que
tel en fait dans un cadre très général
ce calcul de gradient peut être si l'on
qui n'est pas raisonnable de l'effectuer
en pratique en particulier pour une
machine quelconque je vous déconseille
d'entreprendre ce calcul cependant comme
je lai brièvement mentionné dans
l'épisode précédent
il se trouve que dans le cas des réseaux
de neurones les gradients sont
formidablement simple à calculer comme
on le verra la semaine prochaine et
c'est vraiment ça à mon sens ce qui fait
le succès des réseaux de neurones en
fait cette faculté à être guidé par un
gradient semble si crucial que certains
chercheurs comme yann le cun préfère
désormais parler de programmation
différentiel c'est-à-dire de
programmation qui sapent il presque
exclusivement sur le fait d'être guidés
par les gradients déduit de performances
de la machine sur des données
d'entraînement
selon ian qu'un le futur de
l'informatique c'est la programmation
différentiel donc ce jour-là capitulaire
descente de gradient ça consiste à
partir d'abord d'un réglage quelconque
ils ont ensuite procédé à des itérations
pour améliorer au fur et à mesure ce
réglage la première étape c'est de
calculer le gradient qui correspond aux
réglages au cours puis on va suivre les
indications données par ce gradient pour
en déduire un nouveau réglage et il
s'agit ensuite de répéter cette
procédure
encore et encore pour améliorer encore
et encore notre machine alors tout ce
que j'expliquais jusque là peut paraître
assez clair j'espère mais en fait ça
s'applique surtout aucun restreint de
l'apprentissage d'y superviser
c'est à dire le cas où l'on cherche à
prédire la belle à partir des données
comme par exemple prédire la présence de
chats dans une image
malheureusement dans un cas plus
générale d'apprentissage notamment dans
le cas de la précarité non supervisées
il n'est pas forcément évident qu'il
existe une fonction de pertes amis
miser or ces fonctions de perdre sont
vraiment indispensables pour pouvoir
ensuite définir la notion de gradient et
pour pouvoir ensuite effectué de la
descente de gradient on est au moins
sauver la descente de gradient ont ainsi
tendance à diluer ce que l'on veut
vraiment faire pour ceux ramenés un
problème de minimisation de fonction de
pertes
c'est typiquement cette façon de ramener
la formule de bèze un problème de
minimisation de fonction de pertes qui
est au coeur du succès spectaculaire
dégénérative adversaire le network ce
dont on reparlera dans une future vidéo
d'ailleurs même dans le cas de
l'apprentissage superviser il reste le
problème de la surinterprétation dont on
apparaît dans les épisodes 11 à 18 fort
heureusement les chercheurs ont trouvé
une manière de combattre la
surinterprétation tout en restant dans
le cadre d'une programmation
différentiel en introduisant par exemple
la régularisation dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode 18 de façon générale il semble
que le machine learning prometteur c'est
celui qui parvient à intégrer des
notions fondamentales de turing de la
formule deux pays tout en obéissant au
paradigme d'exploration des réglages par
descente de gradient qu'impose le
paradigme de la programmation
différentiel enfin une dernière chose
vous aurez remarqué que le titre de
cette vidéo ne parle pas de descente de
gradient il parle en fait de descendre
de gradient stochastiques
oui parce qu'ils se trouvent qu'en
pratique calculer les performances
exactes d'une configuration de machine
prend beaucoup de temps puisqu'il faut
tester la machine avec un très grand
nombre de données plutôt que de se faire
la descente de gradient stochastique
propose de ne tirer qu'un petit
échantillon de données de calcul le
gradient vis-à-vis de ces données
uniquement et de tourner les réglages
des boutons en fonction de ce gradient
et il se trouve que c'est ainsi que
fonctionnent les algorithmes de machine
learning les plus performants
d'aujourd'hui on peut interpréter cette
descente de gradient stochastique comme
suit à chaque étape on tire quelques
données au hasard on ajuste les
paramètres de notre machine pour aller
dans le sens de l'explication de ces
données sont toutefois cherché à
pleinement expliqué ces données et puis
on réitère ses petits quant à
d'apprentissage un très grand nombre de
fois cet apprentissage forme ensuite une
sorte de danse des paramètres composé de
certains pas parfois étrange mais de
façon cruciale est assez stupéfiante
la combinaison d'un très grand nombre de
ses pas de danse nous guident alors vers
des paramètres plus pertinents qui
peuvent alors donner lieu à une
la chine aux performances surhumaine la
lymphe on a parlé des réseaux de
neurones et gamer 12/13 nous demandent
quel langage utilisé pour pouvoir coder
des réseaux de neurones alors je suis
absolument pas développeur codé de
réseaux de neurones du couvain je vais
pas avoir une réponse forcément très
intelligente mais en gros le truc qui a
l'air d'être utilisé par vraiment pas
mal de gens en tout cas dans mon labo de
recherche
c'est vraiment elle sert flot le truc de
google qui marche vraiment vraiment bien
alors c'est parce que dire à mes
collègues mais moi ça marche vraiment
pas mal c'est passé d'utilisation c'est
souvent utilisé en combinaison avec
python mais je suis sûr vous pouvez
l'utiliser à la plaie avec d'autres
tapis et pour apprendre à mettre les
mains dans le cambouis et a programmé
des réseaux de neurones je vous
recommande les tutoriels de plusieurs
chaînes youtube notamment celle en
français de thibaut neveu et sinon c'est
le côté anglophone qui marche très très
bien de cirage ravale où il ya vraiment
pas mal pas mal de choses sur river
demande si je vais parler des
algorithmes génétiques dans cette série
sur un silence artificielle et la
réponse est non en tout cas pas dans un
épisode dédié du coup j'en parle le
matin très rapidement ce qui est amusant
c'est que les algorithmes génétiques
c'est une idée qui a été proposé par
alan turing encore une fois dans son
papier 2950 vraiment essayé de poser la
question de comment est-ce qu'on en
arrive et un cerveau humain
et voilà c'est rapide ont bien que m
l'évolution darwinienne eu un rôle très
important à jouer dans ce développement
de la complexité du cerveau humain et du
coup turing a proposé très naturellement
l'idée que des intelligences
artificielles soient conçues et
optimisées et apprises à partir de
principes similaires aléas sélection
darwinienne
et c'est ainsi que sont nés un peu les
algorithmes génétiques alors très
rapidement le principe est bien sûr très
inspirée de la biologie mais en
particulier de trois aspects de la
biologie le premier c'est de maintenir
en vie une population assez diversifié
de différence d'intelligence
artificielle
donc on va pas chercher uniquement à
voir le la meilleure possible
l'intelligence artificielle mais on va
essayer de s'assurer ce qu'est une
certaine diversité dans une famille
d'intelligence artificielle
ensuite la deuxième étape c'est à croire
a consisté à faire des croisements et
des mutations pour créer des nouveaux
des nouvelles variantes en fait noté
lyon-st artificielle qui sont peut-être
combiné ensuite avec d'autres
d'algorithmes d'apprentissage pour
appeler les optimiser
petit peu parce qu'il suffit pas de
faire un croisement c'est a priori le
croisement avait donné lieu à quelque
chose qui est pas terrible mais si on
prend quelque chose de pas terrible - ce
sera peut-être nouveaux
et s'ils ont ensuite on les ducs on aura
peut-être quelque chose qui sera du même
niveau que notre famille notre
population
l'attirance artificielle et de temps en
temps on parfois d'un truc qui sera bien
meilleur et enfin le troisième aspect
très important c'est la sélection qui va
consister en essentiellement à supprimer
de la population d'intelligence
artificielle les intelligences
artificielles qui sont les moins
performantes et ainsi au fur et à mesure
des itérations et des générations on
peut s'attendre à ce que la population
de l'intelligence artificielle
s'améliore au fur et à mesure et
atteignent des niveaux qui serait
difficile à calculer autrement ce qui
est assez contre actif c'est que ce
principe très simple qui combine du coup
avoir une population diversifiée créer
des mutations et sélectionner uniquement
les meilleurs en tout cas supprimer les
moins bons ces trois principes très
simples suffisent à ce moment avoir des
performances qui sont sur humaine on se
rend souvent ça peut résoudre des
problèmes temps mais beaucoup
d'application des problèmes qui sont
souvent une paix durable par exemple le
voyageur de commerce où on arrivait
assez facilement avoir principalement on
arrive à voir aujourd'hui des solutions
qui sont meilleurs que ceux qu'un humain
serait capable de trouver et qui sont
même parfois meilleur que tout autre
algorithme qui a été proposé donc il
arrive que ces principes très très
basique qui ne repose pas sur 7 des
séances de gradient et sur un indicateur
de dire dans quel sens tournai bouton
parfois se fait de tournée vous ton
semble parfois limités pour certains
problèmes et du coup pour à ces
problèmes là il peut être utile d'avoir
d'autres méthodes comme par exemple les
algorithmes génétiques
donc si je devais parier je dirais que
la descente de gradient reste un truc
extrêmement important qui sera
certainement un composant central dans
l'intelligence artificielle du futur
mais peut-être que très probablement
même ça ne suffira pas et qu'il faudra
combiner ça pas mal d'autres techniques
comme par exemple ces idées des
algorithmes génétiques
je pense aussi des idées comme des trucs
un peu plus bas et vient comme les
méthodes d'échantillonnage notamment
monte-carlo mark mark of kings seront
des méthodes qui vont jouer aussi des
rôles importants
à venir je vous renvoie à terme envers
mon livre où je parle de pas mal de ses
différents algorithmes
enfin un cafard demande si un réseau de
neurones est capable d'apprécier mais
n'importe quelle fonction est ce que ça
veut dire qu'elle est capable
d'apprécier la formule de belize en gros
la réponse à cette question et non pour
des raisons parfois un peu compliqué
mais même au delà de ça en fait il y à
des fonctions que de façon pragmatique
les réseaux de nos ne seront pas
capables d'à proxy mais pour une raison
assez simple c'est que la taille du
réseau de neurones nécessaire pour
approximer ses fonctions pourraient être
exponentiellement grand donc vraiment
irréalisable dans notre univers dont par
exemple il est possible que pour
certaines fonctions pour avoir une
approximation assez bonne de cette
fonction le réseau de neurones doit
avoir un google de neurones ce qui est
pas ce qui rentre pas dans l'univers
observable puisqu'il ya moins d'un
google de particules dans l'univers
observable et en fait ça peut souvent
même à être bien pire que ça puisqu'on
peut avoir des configurations il faut un
googleplex de neurones par exemple pour
pouvoir approcher une certaine fonction
du coup il ya son problème de la
complexité en fait du réseau de neurones
qui est absolument primordiale à prendre
en compte est en fait c'est une raison
additionnelle pour laquelle la le terme
de l'universalité des réseaux de
neurones est loin d' être conclusif
quant au fait que les réseaux de
neurones sont la solution ultime au
machine learning
bref j'aurais tendance à dire que
l'auteur de l'approximation universel
c'est un peu une condition un peu
nécessaire pour le succès des réseaux de
neurones mais ca tue ne sont pas
suffisants pour l'expliquer et il me
semble que vraiment le truc qui fait que
les réseaux de neurones marche aussi
bien
c'est le fait qu'ils se prête très bien
à la descente de gradient et donc à la
programmation différentiel elle espère
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo la
prochaine fois on va parler de comment
est ce qu'avec un réseau de neurones on
peut calculer assez facilement le
gradient du réseau de neurones dans
certaines données et tout ça va reposer
sur un algorithme qu'on appelle la rétro
propagation ou encore bach propagation
propre en anglais si vous avez aimez
cette vidéo pensez à la ligue et à la
commenter a partagé conserver d'abonnés
pour notamment cris futurs épisodes
maire ce type en power dont et j'espère
que vous serez là la prochaine fois la
barre des 50
[Musique]
un de gaines indiqué mme jackson